hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
the fuel cell analyses of checkpoint
inhibition
induced myocarditis implications into
mechanisms of severe immune related
adverse events i am sabrina lemoos of
lab roots and i'll be your moderator for
today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermostat science fix
to learn more visit www.thermofisher.com
let's get started before we begin i
would like to remind everyone that this
event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the support
tab found at the top right of the
presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credit
please click on the continuing education
credits tab
located at the top right of the
presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credit
i now present today's speaker justin m
balco the associate professor department
of medicine and pathology
microbiology and immunology at
vanderbilt university medical center
for a complete biography on our speakers
please visit the biography tab at the
top
of your screen dr balco welcome you may
now begin your presentation
okay thank you very much for having me
i'm very excited to
talk about this subject which is a
research direction that i was
not particularly planning on going on in
my career but has been something that
we've become very interested in
so my lab in nashville tennessee at
vanderbilt ingram cancer center
is primarily focused on how to make
immunotherapies work better in patients
through a translational approach
we do this in a couple of different ways
you know we started off by trying to
understand
what some of the biomarkers are in
patients that might predict
response to immunotherapies because that
helps us use
these agents more effectively in the
clinic a second thrust of research in
our lab
is to try to make them work
immunotherapies work better
by combining them with other small
molecule inhibitors chemotherapy
or other immunotherapies in order to try
to broaden and deepen responses in
patients
the last way in which we try to make
immunotherapies work better in my
laboratory
is by trying to understand how to risk
mitigate so just like any therapeutic
immune checkpoint inhibitors or
immunotherapies
can have significant and severe
toxicities
although these differ in their mechanism
from many other drugs that we have
experienced with
in treating cancer patients and so today
i'm going to be talking about that last
item there is trying to understand some
of the immune related toxicities
that are associated with immunotherapies
so many of you may be familiar if you're
in cancer therapy or
simply pay attention to the media
immunotherapies
have really transformed cancer therapy
over the last five to ten years
so two of these agents which are
approved in a variety of different
cancer types
are uh
igg monoclonal antibodies which target
the pd-1 pdl1 pathways as well as the
ctla4 pathway
so both of these pathways and the
understanding that these were
checkpoint inhibitors that could
alter the outcome of cancer and could be
therapeutic and
therapeutically employed in cancer
patients was really some of the
transformative research that won the
nobel prize
just about a year and a half ago and so
both pd-1 pdl-1 and the ctla-4 pathways
are ways to inhibit mechanisms of
peripheral tolerance so both of these
molecules
in of themselves are are ways that our
body can
inhibit reactivity against cells
so typically ctoa 4 is
a ligand which will bind
to the b7 family of co-stimulatory
receptors
on the dendritic cells or professional
antigen presenting cells
although initially this was thought to
occur primarily in
lymph nodes we now know that this can
also occur
in in tumor sites or in sites of
inflammation
and there's a potential couple other
mechanisms in which
ctla4 or inhibition of ctoa 4
might stimulate immune responses now pd1
and pdl1
these molecules the ligand and the
receptor the receptor being
existing on t cells so the pd-1
molecules shown in the bottom right
corner here at least in the concept or
in the context of cancer therapy
combined either pdl1 or pdl2
although the schematic here shows these
molecules present on tumor cells we now
know that they can also be on a variety
of other cell types including other t
cells macrophages and other stromal
cells
and so the interaction between this
pathway has the ability to
shut off t cells at the site of
inflammation
this causes a so-called exhaustion
phenotype
and limits the functionality of the t
cells to do their job which in this case
would be the destruction
of tumor cells going back to ctoa ctla4
this interaction
in the draining lymph node of the tumor
is actually known to are thought to at
least by one mechanism
limit the co-stimulation and the
activation the initial activation of t
cells which causes them to leave the
draining lymph node and seek out the
site of
inflammation so both of these mechanisms
are presumably purpose in nature for the
prevention of autoimmunity and control
of acute inflammation
however we now know that tumors can
actually hijack these pathways
and use these pathways to avoid
anti-tumor immunity
so as i mentioned while these
checkpoint inhibitors these monoclonal
antibodies can be
very efficacious in a variety of tumor
types particularly in combination
with many drugs including these types of
inhibitors we can have
significant toxicities and what's
strange is that you know with many small
molecule or targeted inhibitors with
many chemotherapies
the toxicities can be very predictable
so we know you know for instance taxans
and cancer therapy have
a high degree of peripheral neuropathy
and these have been sort of well
characterized and in many cases we can
control those toxicities we can
pre-medicate
um and based on our understanding of how
those work
however toxicity immune checkpoint
inhibitors is
is widespread and sporadic and can
affect a number of different
organ systems shown on the left here
there's also a variety of potential
sources of the ways that these
inhibitors might affect different organs
now the toxicities to immune checkpoint
inhibitors are often
autoimmune autoimmune-like so they they
induce what are called itises so
inflammation of different organs
or organ systems
our group has had a very strong interest
in the mechanisms and the clinical
presentation of these different
uh checkpoint inhibitor toxicities i'll
try to consistently refer them
refer to them as immune related adverse
events and you can see in
a gem oncology paper that our group
published a couple years ago
where we've looked at across large
databases of the world health
organization's
reporting of drug toxicities and looked
at the number of ira ease that were
reported versus their fatality rate
what i want to draw your attention to
here
is you know some of the most common ones
colitis pneumonitis hepatitis while they
do have a fatality rate
one of the highest fatality rates of any
of these while being very rare
is this third from the bottom one called
myocarditis which essentially
means inflammation of the heart the
fatality rate when myocarditis occurs
can approach 50 of patients so this is
while a very rare toxicity occurring in
one percent or less of patients treated
with the combination of anti-ctla4 and
anti-pd1
remains a significant hazard to the
deployment of these immunotherapies
so our program at vanderbilt has started
this center
called the v point program which is the
vanderbilt program for optimizing immune
oncology therapy
this combines a number of different
efforts both from the from the clinical
side so clinical efforts where we
clinically phenotype
and organize multi-center projects again
with
collaborating institutions across the
country and across the world
we try to institute clinical trials in
which case we either prevent or
treat these immune related adverse
events this also incorporates
translational efforts
so systematic collection of samples from
patients that are either
do you have iras in response to immune
checkpoints or don't
um in an overall effort to try to both
validate mechanisms correlatively and
also identify biomarkers that might
predict
which patients are most at risk for
these immune related toxicities
we also have basic science efforts my
lab
functioning both at the translational
and the basic science side
where we try to explore either distinct
mouse models or cell culture models
with high dimensional characterization
in order to better understand some of
these iraes at the molecular level
[Music]
so our group um so i kind of got pulled
into this
uh way back in 2015 2016
when a melanoma oncologist is a close
collaborator of mine
douglas johnson who runs our melanoma
program here at vanderbilt
and his mentor at the time dr jeff
sosman is now at northwestern
in chicago as well as job and most
ladies
well known for helping to establish the
cardio oncology field
which examines the cardiotoxic
effects of many different oncology drugs
and so what happened was uh
dr johnson johnson came into my my lab
one day
and and told me that they had had two
patients uh in the clinic that were
being treated with a combination of
anti-pd1 and anti-ctoa iv
that within one week of their first dose
and one week of one another
had both presented into the er with
severe fatigue
very strong cardiac arrhythmias that
were not compatible with life
unfortunately both of these patients
passed away they were very convinced
that this was
in response to this combination immune
checkpoint blockade although they had
treated a number of patients and had not
observed these toxicities
there were some rare case reports from
clinical trials
and from clinical use across the country
that really uh substantiated that this
was likely due to
immune the immune activation secondary
to deployment of these
checkpoint inhibitors our group studied
from autopsy samples from each of these
patients
um at a molecular level both in the
heart in the tumor
as well as the skeletal muscle of the
patients so
many of these are both of these patients
also presented with with what was called
myositis which was an inflammation
of the skeletal muscle which in some
respects can be
similar to cardiac muscle and most
different from
smooth muscle within the body
and so what i want to draw your
attention to here was just one figure
from that paper
in one of the patients where we were
looking at t-cell receptors or t-cell
clones
that we identified by sequencing in that
patient's pre-treatment tumor versus the
post-treatment tumor
and showing that after treatment there
were a number of shared t-cell receptor
clones
that were now present both in the tumor
as well as in the cardiac muscle at
autopsy
what this data suggests or what these
data suggests is
that the treatment with ici therapy
caused an expansion of t
cells that were at least found in both
the tumor as well as now
in the afflicted tissue which caused the
patient's death
within this paper we also did some
histological analysis
just to show the degree of uh within the
consequence and severity of this
particular toxicity when it occurs
on the left you can see a normal heart
so you see these very organized
cells and muscle fibers that stretch
across
very few dense purple nuclei
and then on the right you can see from
one of the patients that died of
myocarditis these
larger dense nuclei that are lymphocytes
and so these lymphocytes appear to be
predominating
in areas of the heart where what we have
is called myocyte dropout
you can see now this disorganization of
the muscle cells
within the heart and that has obviously
been some severe consequences and
destruction of those cells
which cause death so uh immune
checkpoint inhibitor induced myocarditis
what we found here was that it had a
high degree of t
cell and macrophage infiltration in
inside striated muscle
um this was associated with
electrocardiogram abnormalities and
arrhythmias
um and overall through looking at many
large databases we determined this had
about a one percent incidence with
combination
therapy the problem is the who and the
when so this is early and unpredictable
and when it occurs as i mentioned can
have about a 50 mortality
the combination uh there's a combination
effect within these patients
where often they have what's been
described as a triad
a myosinic like a myosin a gravis-like
syndrome
as well as often at times concomitant
with myositis
it's also although only occurring in
about one percent of patients
this presents a larger problem as there
are other heart and vessel
problems that can be associated with the
deployment of these therapeutics
these include other arrhythmias that are
not associated with myocarditis
pericarditis and vasculitis all of these
can have a high mortality rate in
patients
so this is some additional immunes to
chemistry just sort of validating this
idea
that there were a large number of t
cells in the heart both cd4 and cd8
cells predominate while plasma cells
identified by cd138 are are largely
negative within the tissue or the
affected tissue
as well as just general b cells so
looking at cd20 on the bottom
left now there is a large degree of
macrophage infiltrate
um identified here by cd68 immune
chemistry staining
the importance of this is presently
unclear but something we see very
frequently
so one of the first things we wanted to
do is get a broader understanding of
what was going on within these patient
tissues
we initially deployed a strategy called
geomix
from nanostring essentially this is an
in situ
technology where uh tissue sections are
labeled with
about 40 different protein based
antibodies or protein
targeted antibodies with uv
photoclivable barcoded
nucleic acid linkers the tissue is also
visualized with several fluorescent
antibodies
after staining one can visualize the
tissue architecture with the
immunofluorescent antibodies
select different cell populations and or
regions of interest on that slide hit
those regions with
a uv light which releases the barcodes
and then
sip those barcodes off from that region
and count them
and so these are just some of the
immunofluorescence images this was from
one of the myocarditis
specimens you can see that we have
immunostain here with cd3
to mark t cells within the tissue
desmond which will mark the striated
muscle fibers and muscle cells
and then adapty stain which is uh
presented here
in false color gray
and so looking across these different 40
markers without spending too much time
on this one of the things that we did
identify was that in these regions with
a lot of t-cell infiltrate
that we saw a high degree of cytotoxic
and memory activated
uh cycling t-cell markers so a high
degree of
a high degree of branzine b expression
within those
t cell rich regions and the expression
of the cd45
ro marker which mar which marks memory
cells
so um we began collaborating with
uh the with dr jim allison nobel prize
laureate from
2018 um his laboratory who had
approached
javed musli our cardiologists
collaborator
where they had these mice uh in the
black sex background
that were heterozygous for ctoa iv
and homozygous for loss of pd1 so the
gene pdcd1
which which encodes pd-1 what they
noticed was
any time you lost both copies of
anti-ctla-4 these mice
regardless of their pd-1 status they
come very early to
widespread autoimmunity in the presence
of a a single copy or no copies lost to
c2a4 these mice went on to live normal
happy lives and they caught in the
context of heterozygous loss of ctoa iv
but complete uh presence or hemizygous
loss of pd1
again the mice seem to be generally fine
what was interesting was in in the
context of complete loss of pd1
and heterozygous loss of c2a4 now
looking at the leftmost graph
these mice the red line here had a
a high degree of sudden death syndrome
that occurs beginning about four to six
weeks into
life and so in examining pathologically
these particular mice and the cause of
death
it was determined that
these mice were actually dying very
specifically of
myocarditis which replicated what we
observed
clinically in patients that were treated
with combinations of therapeutics that
target these same molecules
another interesting finding from the
study was that the for some reason
the propensity of these mice which has
incomplete penetrance this phenotype
seems to be more predominant in female
mice and that's shown at the survival
curve on the right on the left-hand side
of the screen
so female mice had a significantly
greater death rate
and we actually see this in data from
the world health organization where
females seem to be
slightly more susceptible to ici-induced
myocarditis
these mice also present with a variety
of different arrhythmias
which replicate what we observe in human
patients so shown here some
ecg's that have been performed on the
mice with
loss of pd1 and heterozygous loss of
c2a4
sinus arrest and av block you can sort
of see normal sinus rhythm in wild-type
mice
and in mice with lacking pd1 but having
complete uh
presence of the ctla4 alleles on the lap
in the right uh most uh plot we're
showing
um the percent of mice that have
conduction disorders so we do see a
small amount of conduction disorders
uh in in some of the mice that lack pd1
but it is nowhere near the amount
of those that lack a single copy of
ctla4 in the conference in the context
of complete pd-1 loss
there's also this additional bar in this
which i'll get to in a moment just
remember
that treatment with the drug of a bad
asset in that high risk group of
mice seems to ablate these conduction
disorders and we'll get into an
explanation of this in a few slides
so getting into some single cell
analysis we now have this mouse model
you know it can be very difficult to do
perform single cell analysis in patients
with myocarditis the heart tissue
is not something that's very easy to
sample or to biopsy
and so getting site of toxicity tissue
and being able to do live cell analysis
can be
an extreme challenge occasionally it can
be done when a biopsy is taken
but many times these are emergent
situations they're highly dangerous to
the patient and that biopsy tissue is
needed for diagnosis
of immune checkpoint inhibitor-induced
myocarditis
however we now have this mirroring model
which seems to replicate the clinical
phenotype and so
we turn to leveraging this model for
single cell analysis
and so these are some flow cytometry
data just showing a very sort of crude
analysis here
in that the hearts of
mice affected so the pd1 knockout
anti-ctla4 heterozygous
c-57 black sex mice have a very high
degree or enrichment of cd45 positive
immune cells
within that digested and dissociated
hard on death
so i'm doing a more careful
characterization of what these cd45
positive cells are
so looking again um the best comparison
here the red dots versus the blue dots
the gray dots are the wild type mice
you can see that there is just like what
we saw in patients there is a high
degree of
but hetero heterogeneous infiltration of
cd8 and cd4 cells
uh within the context of this particular
miriam model
as well as cd68 and these were the only
markers that we looked at where there
was a significant difference
between those individual groups and so
it just so happens that these are the
three
broad phenotypes that we do see our
immunophenotypes that we see
in patients that have uh succumbed to
immune checkpoint inhibitor induced
myocarditis
so um one of the next things that we
wanted to explore
was we had this hypothesis that
myocarditis in in these mice
were enriched for oligoclonal t cells so
given that both of these agents
act on t cells and can are known to
induce autoimmunity resulting from
autoreactive t
cells we wanted to test the hypothesis
that there was an anagen specific t
cell expansion within these within these
mice
so we're able to do this by quantifying
tcr recombination and the clonotypes
which exist within different
environments most importantly here
within the heart
of mice that have succumbed to immune to
the loss of pd1 and the heterozygous
loss of c2a4 resulting in myocarditis
so shown here on the left are the number
of hyper-expanded clones and what i mean
by hyperexpanded clones are the t cell
receptors in which we
when we sequence we see those same t
cell receptors many many times in the
same tissue
since presumably one should have a very
large and diverse repertoire of t cell
receptors
existing only a few times within the the
body
the detection of multiple copies of
these same tcr's are generally
indicative of the concept of clonal
expansion
meaning those t cells have activated in
response to an antigen
and then have expanded either in lymph
nodes or systemically or in the site of
a toxicity or inflammation and so what i
want you to notice here that
in the healthy heart of mice or in
wild-type mouth spleens
we see a very high degree of diversity
and very low degree
of clonality however in t-cell receptor
sequencing from the heart of
mice that died of myocarditis within
that genetic group that we've been
focusing on
you can see that the vast majority of t
cell receptors identified there are
highly clonal now interestingly looking
across
seven different mice that died of famine
and myocarditis
um and also a couple of uh wild type
c-57 black six
splenic tissue is controlled what you
can see is that
while there's a very high degree of
clonality or t cells that have expanded
within those mice
the degree of overlap is extremely low
and in fact
none of those clonal or very oligoclonal
t cell receptors identified in one mouse
were typically identified in any of the
other mice and this is because
largely the repertoire within these mice
even though they're genetically matched
is largely stoictastic and random
there are some selection processes but
this is also
represented in the human level in the
knowledge that the t cell repertoire
between two identical genetically
identical twins
is actually two percent or less of their
t cell receptors
so this actually makes sense that we
don't detect the same t
cell receptor however this does not uh
this does not refute the hypothesis that
a common antigen might be responsible
for
this phenotype within this model
[Music]
so looking at this a different way you
can see this is just the circles plot of
the v
and j recombination which is largely
dictating
the cdr3 or the complementary
determining region
three of the t cell receptors we
identified on the left is the heart
tissue from a foaming myocarditis mouse
and on the right is the spleen from the
same mouse and so you can see on the
right the spaghetti plot there shows
that there's a very very high degree of
diversity there's very little call
expansion in the spleen
however on the left in the myocarditis
in the heart tissue
you can see that several clones or
separate v to j recombination events
are highly predominant within that
tissue
so now we've turned to a alternative
single cell approach which is
single cell rna sequencing so we this
was a real challenge because you have to
have
very good viability of your samples to
perform single cell rna
in which case can be very difficult in
this model because the mice are fine
they're fine and then all of a sudden
within 24 hour period
they can get very sick and even die
overnight without any indication that
they actually have myocarditis
our lab and javits lab have struggled
with
identifying sort of a biomarker or a
predictive biomarker of
identifying the mice and how to know
when they're actually sick where we'll
be able to sacrifice those mice
and study the mechanism more closely
however this was from one mouse that
appeared to be very sick and so we were
able to get a live cell dissociation
from this mouse
we had to combine six different
wild-type black six mice as comparators
in this experiment because
the of the very low frequency and
presence of immune cells within
a normal healthy mouse's heart um and so
what i want to draw your attention to on
the left is just the umat plot where
these different islands of cells
where the the individual cells have been
colored whether they're
from the heterozygous c2i4 or pd1
knockout mouse
or a wild type mouse you can see that
there's general presence of all these
populations in both mice for both groups
of mice
remembering again that there were six
wild-type mice compared to one
heterozygous mouse
you can see that there's a large number
of b cells in the wild type mouse versus
the heterozygous mouse we believe that
that's an artifact of the fact that we
combined six different hearts in order
to do this experiment
we believe this could be just due to
inappropriate uh
contamination of just small amounts of
peripheral blood due to the processing
what we do see is that there's a very
strong sort of phenotypic
change in the cd8 compartment within
these mics
so that's outlined by the circle here on
the left
we also see that there's this sort of
new myeloid population which we've been
talking about several times in the
presence of cd68 population
that we observe in the hearts of both
human and mice suffering from
myocarditis
and so what was interesting is we also
had single cell level t cell receptor
sequencing data on these same single
cells
so we're now able to look at those
clonal tcrs were able to match alpha and
beta
chains of the t cell receptors and were
able to separate
in that heterozygous myocarditis mouse's
heart the t cell receptors based on
whether they were clonal being
expanded or whether they existed only a
single time within
our single cell rna-seq data and what i
want you to appreciate here in the
middle plot is that the vast majority of
these clonal t
cells express cd8 and they do not
express
cd4 so this experiment prompted us to
look a little bit deeper
and to say okay so is the myocarditis
that we're observing in these mice
is this a cd8 or a cd4 mediated effect
so you can see in the survival curve
that with no treatment about 50 of these
mice
succumb to myocarditis
within about two to three months after
reading with the administration of
depleting antibodies to
cd4 we see no change in that survival
however when we deplete cd8 cells we see
a near abrogation of mortality due to
myocarditis
so looking at the predominant uh
t cell receptor alpha and beta chain
within our single cell sequencing data
we're able to combine those um that
predominant clone which was highly
expressed
within the heart tissue of that one
mouse that we did single cell
analysis on and what we were able to do
is do a computational analysis across
what's known about
the uh the b allele for mhc
class one now knowing that this is a
class one restricted antigen
and looking at things that are expressed
specifically in heart tissue versus
other organs and so doing a
computational approach and then re
recombine recombining both the alpha and
the beta alleles
in a recombinant pcr and then
transducing a mirroring cd8 t
cell line called the 5kc t cell line
we're able to reconstitute that t cell
receptor and we now have a model to
study
antigen specificity of that t cell
receptor
as a control we uh reconstituted the ot1
t cell receptor which recognizes the syn
cycle antigen
so these uh 5kc cells will express
interleukin 2
in response to the appropriate anagenic
stimulate stimulation
we're using bone marrow derived
dendritic cells from the c57 black six
mouse in order to perform this
experiment
and when co-cultured with an ot1 t-cell
receptor expressing t-cells
those bone marrow dendritic cells
respond only
uh by idle two secretion only to that
low value and peptides
and fecal and that's shown in the upper
right here now in that
c1 clone which is that very predominant
t cell receptor which we reconstituted
in similar cells we see that the
predicted
antigen from a cardiac specific
transcript
is now inducing the expression of
interleukin-2
specifically within the t cells that
express
that clone so we now think we know at
least some potential idea of what the
cardiac antigen is
in which case uh loss of pd-1 and ctoa 4
is now releasing peripheral tolerance
against
so given that these findings
appear to be at least partially
dependent on a haploid sufficiency of
anti-ctoa iv
collaborators of ours in france
in which case that had a patient
with myocarditis last year published
this letter in new england journal of
medicine
where they hypothesized that given no
other options in this particular patient
who was
very clearly going to die from immune
checkpoint inhibitor-induced biocarditis
that the administration of a drug called
the batacept which is the
the ctla-4 molecule fused to the fc
region of igg-1 for therapeutic
administration
often used in a transplant rejection
might reverse this phenotype for this
toxicity
and so i encourage you to go out and
read this letter it's a very short read
very interesting if you're clinically
sort of oriented this patient had a very
rapid recovery
with administration of a better step and
after about a week was able to leave the
hospital
and continue on in their life um and so
we hypothesized that perhaps
if representative of this clinical uh
scenario that mice treated with a bad
accept
given the fact that there is this
propensity of these mice to develop
checkpoint inhibitor reduce myocarditis
just
like a combination treated patients um
that a dataset might reverse this
phenotype so just like we saw in our cd8
depletion
the administration of a badassep to this
group of of mice that lacked pd1
and had or heterozygous for anti-ctla4
specifically in the females that were
most susceptible to
myocarditis-induced death you can see
that this massively reversed this
phenotype and these mice were now
able to uh able to survive
so in looking at the cd45 positive
infiltration within the cardiac tissue
again we can now see
that there's in the vehicle treated mice
there's this enrichment of cd45 positive
infiltrating cells within the heart
tissue
this takes a little while to go down so
in about two weeks we don't really see
any difference in the absolute number of
uh cd45 positive cells within that
tissue
however by 14 weeks out we're able to
see that these mice now
look like a wild type c57 black six mice
so this replicates at least this one
case study that
was published that a bad accept might be
a suitable treatment for
this myocarditis when it occurs
so we wanted to study this on a little
bit more mechanistic basis we
are certainly still looking at how
common this myocarditis
inducing antigen is in the cardiac
tissue in the mice how common is it
among different mice
is it able to you know is immunization
with that peptide
capable of causing myocarditis in the
black sex model
and what are the possibilities that that
antigen is similar or the same
at least in its protein source in human
patients
however we wanted to understand a little
bit more about these t cells
on an immune phenotyping backbone or
background or context
and so we employed scitoff or mass
cytometry
on the cardiac infiltrating cells so
this is just another example of single
cell
analysis that we've performed in order
to answer our questions
this is a disney plot you can see where
we're able to
identify all the different predominant
immune populations again
the most predominant one being cda
positive t
cells showing the upper right of the six
panel quadrant in the bottom left corner
of the screen
um and then also high uh constituents of
cd11b positive cells our myeloid cells
and our cp4 positive cells
so this cytoph data replicates what we
saw by single cell sequencing what we
saw by standard flow cytometry
we also had this one really interesting
finding
within these data so looking at cd86
which if you remember right
is one of the two co-stimulatory
ligands for cd28 mt cells but also
that is blocked by ctla4
and so presumably a drug like a bataceft
would
directly bind to cd86 as well as c80
those can occur on professional answer
presenting cells we're actually quite
interested to see that these
cd8 cells that we see within the um
within the myocardium or infiltrating
cells within a myocardium
was was uh highly present uh cd86 was
highly present on those cd8 cells
so it's not really well understood what
a cosimulatory molecule might be doing
um on t cells within an inflammatory
micro environment
although it is well known that
analytical ii can induce in sites of
inflammation
the expression of cd86 but not its
partner cd80
on t cells and other cells within an
immune micro environment
and so we've actually started to explore
this in a lab as a possible alternative
mechanism for the action of a better set
so is it possible that cd 86 on those t
cells might be a direct target of a bad
acceptance we're now trying to
understand
whether cd 86 expression on t cells
can uh either stimulate and cis or
entrance other t
cells and whether a bad assets
functionality within at least this model
and or human patients might be
associated with its ability to bind cd86
shown here on an apc but now we know
also expressed on t
cells within this micro environment and
this uh
we're hypothesizing could be a potential
mechanism because of this rapid recovery
that we see whenever we treat
either mice or in some cases humans with
a bad asset
which isn't consistent with an already
prime t cell response
secondary to the administration of
anti-ctla4
so in conclusions um we know that
myocarditis can be caused by immune
checkpoint inhibition
this can be associated with t cell
expansion at a phenotype of memory
activated
cd8 positive t cells at least within
this model that we're looking at here
as well as in some human patients in
mice genetic loss of pd-1
requires heterozygous loss of anti-ctoa
4
in order to induce myocarditis that
seems to approximate that which we
observe
in patients myocarditis in mice
seems to be associated with
oligoexpansion oligoclonal expansion of
private tcrs in each individual mouse
and in humans we have some data
there which i we haven't presented here
today
but in in general at least in mice this
seems to be predominantly cba we're now
looking at uh trying to explore um how
likely it is in either cd8 or cd4
across human patients as well in order
to see how well we think we're actually
recapitulating
the etiology and pathogenesis in human
patients
in both mice and humans the delivery of
a body sets appears to reverse or
protect against myocarditis and cardiac
inflammation
due to loss or inhibition of these
immune checkpoints
and we're now exploring cd86 possible
uh t cells as a possible mechanism of
action of a bad assembly
um finally i showed you sort of some
provocative but early data that
we might have identified the target
anagen and mice and humans
but you know are really holding off on
reporting on this until we're convinced
that
this wasn't just a single mouse that is
consistent among mice and whether this
is translatable
to the target antigens and and the
parallels there in humans
and so with that i want to acknowledge
uh you know many many people
this isn't all our laboratories work in
fact we're just
really performing a a small but integral
part of this
um our funding is is by a variety of
sources but specifically for this
project
uh two main sources the national
institutes of health of both dr moss
leahy javed muslih and myself and doug
johnson
have several grants within this area
either specifically studying myocarditis
doug johnson and i have an nih
provocative questions grant that is
focused on
identifying the mechanisms and
biomarkers of immune-related adverse
events in general secondary to
checkpoint any of their
therapies um the number of people in my
lab
who uh we like to call the cardiac kids
as well as in java's lab who you know
would stay up late and you know be
processing
um these samples either from clinical
patients or from mice whatever the
sort of the unexpected um the unexpected
findings would occur
that we would need to you know suddenly
have a big mouth take down day
or or we have new clinical samples that
need to be processed immediately
and so obviously we couldn't do that
without their expertise and
excitement and enthusiasm a number of
different clinical pathologists we work
with
as well as t-cell biologists and then
finally
you know the model which has provided a
lot of the the insight into this
provided by
uh james allison's lab at md anderson
and his postdoc spencer way would
initially describe this finding
and so our lab is working closely with
theirs to try to
translate some of these findings to
helping patients that are being treated
with these immune
immune therapies and to better
understand
these immune toxicities when they occur
we also had some support for nanostring
in order to
deploy some of their spatial profiling
techniques which i think was you know
very helpful in us
sort of driving our more specific single
cell analysis techniques downstream
so with that i'd be happy to open it up
to
any questions the audience might have
thank you dr belfo for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen and we'll answer as
many questions as we have
time for let's get started
our first question dr belko is what are
some ways that single cell
analyses have really provided a unique
opportunity
to answer your research questions in
this project
sure so that's a great question and as
you know the
the immune system can be highly complex
and as soon as you have an initial
inflammation or insult you know
oftentimes what we observe is
sort of this mass flooding or sequential
flooding of that tissue with
all different components of the innate
and adaptive immune system
so sorting out what's really going on
there is a very complex technique
um many times you know the pathogenesis
of
immune related toxicities of
autoimmunity or
or even an anti-tumor immunity can be
dependent on very small populations of
cells
you might not be looking for you might
need a large number
you know of different markers in order
to really identify those cells
and to get a better understanding of
what's going on either transcriptionally
or you know phenotyping
within that population of cells i don't
think that we could do
this type of analysis or really answer
this research
project or question uh without being
able to employ those
those technologies that allow us to very
quickly and facile
and it feels to seal fashion figure out
what's different you know what's going
on and
and what how are those cells changing
how are they adapting to that
environment
how how can we how can we answer that
question without
looking at a single cell level and the
last
sort of answer to that would be the t
cell receptor sequencing and our single
cell
rna sequencing in order to understand
what the t
cell receptors are and what they might
be recognizing
one has to be able to link two different
genes the alpha and the beta
receptors or alpha and beta chains for
the t cell receptors
together in order to know what that
pairing is and then a mishmash of rna
sequencing data or even t
cell receptor sequencing data without
looking at the single cell level there's
simply no
real confident way in order to pair
those alpha and beta chains
localize them to the same cell because
you require both of those chains to be
sequenced
in the same cell in order to dictate
what its
cdr3 region actually is
wonderful thank you dr balco our next
question is
what is the major impact of this work
for example
how can knowing the mechanism of
ici-induced
myocarditis lead to changes in the way
we treat patients yeah i mean i think
that the major impact
is is pretty broad you know i hope that
we're able to completely figure out this
mechanism
um and you know i'm confident that we
will um
the you i think it's easiest to answer
that in the context of examples
so if if we have a common antigen for
instance that's
that's present in these patients you
know oftentimes what you see are b cell
uh antibodies that are that are produced
in response to
uh inflammation with this in a certain
tissue and many times those b cell
antibodies in the context of
autoimmunity
can be the same or similar um as what
the t cell antigen is and so
you know just as one example is it
possible that some of these patients
already have
some degree of autoimmunity against the
heart and if we're able to figure out
what that antigen is
can we identify for instance the
presence of auto antibodies in those
patients
if we're able to fully characterize the
t cell receptor repertoire
can we identify patients that might be
most at risk because they have either
the right hla types
or the right t cell receptor repertoires
uh already existing prior to being
treated with immune checkpoint inhibitor
therapy that put them at risk
so can we can we risk mitigate can we
identify those patients up front can we
identify them early
um and then sort of a final question you
know or a final
possibility along those lines are could
we if we know the antigen could we
generate for instance tolerant or
vaccine so
vaccines that help to generate
regulatory t
cells or other immunosuppressive arms of
the immune system
against that particular antigen in order
to protect that patient
while still allowing them to be
administered
this highly active combination of
immunotherapies
thank you again dr balco for your time
today and your
important research we would also like to
thank lab roots and our sponsor thermo
fisher scientific for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions that we did not have time for
today and those submitted during the
on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
roots will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time stay healthy goodbye you